you know I didn't realize because as I
said I I really do love your work I
didn't realize that you were in the
pilot for Always Sunny in Philadelphia
yeah I missed that you knew the gang
from Always Sunny is that right I did I
went to school with Glenn Howerton
actually we went to Julliard together
and we were a bunch of unemployed actors
sitting around in LA with nothing to do
and he's like I wrote this bizarre
script with my friend Rob and would you
like to you know to do it and I was like
sure and I read it and it was for the
part of the the chick with the and I was
like yeah the chick with no front butt
right and I thought what am I ever gonna
have a chance to play that on television
so yeah I'm sure now he put it out there
so yeah okay so it was yes you did that
yes that's cool because that show has
gone on to this sort of legend resource
and you were in on the ground floor yeah
well I mean unfortunately I couldn't do
the show when they became a serious cuz
I was doing something else but I'm in
the DVD extras I think or something
that's cool so check it out
you